Ja bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin der Max Zimmer.
Max Zimmer. Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Der Vorname ist Max und der Nachname ist Zimmer. Z I M E R.
Ja Herr Zimmer, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48 Jahre alt und ja wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Könnten Sie das wiederholen? Ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Moment, ich sage Ihnen das gleich, wann ich geboren bin. Ich muss das ausrechnen, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Ja, so etwas kann ich nicht verstehen.
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt und bin geboren.
Entschuldigung, sind Sie 48 oder 78 Jahre alt?
Nein, ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48 Jahre alt.
Genau.
48 Jahre alt, ja.
1978 bin ich geboren, am 1. April.
1. April 1978.
Okay, danke für die Informationen und danke für diese Mühe.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Zimmer?
Ich bin 1,79 Meter groß.
79 groß, ja.
Und wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich habe mich lange nicht gewogen, aber eigentlich ist mein Gewicht immer stabil.
Ich denke, ich wiege so vielleicht 81 Kilogramm.
81 Kilogramm, okay. Ja, wir werden bereits hier auch wieder messen.
Herr Zimmer, was würdest du denn heute zu uns, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, und zwar ist das so, dass ich in letzter Zeit so ein komisches Gefühl habe in der Brust.
Ist das wie ein Schmerz oder ein Druckgefühl oder was für ein Gefühl spüren Sie?
Ja, manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass es mir schwerfällt einzuatmen.
Es ist wie... Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das sagen soll.
Ja, okay.
Dieses Gefühl spüren Sie beim Einatmen oder Ausatmen?
Nein, nein, weder beim Einatmen noch beim Ausatmen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll.
So, als könnte ich dann nicht richtig einatmen.
Okay.
Ja, ich kann Ihre Situation gut verstehen, aber wir sollten das abklären.
Deswegen soll ich diese Beschwerde betreffende Fragen Ihnen stellen.
Okay, seit wann leiden Sie darunter?
Seit wann leide ich darunter? Das habe ich schon länger.
Was meinen Sie bitte länger?
Das habe ich schon so ein paar Wochen schon.
Ein paar Wochen, okay.
Und gibt es etwa einen Auslöser dafür, dass Sie sich solche Beschwerden oder solches Gefühl haben?
Nicht, dass Sie sich, sondern dass Sie solche Beschwerden oder...
Entschuldigung, fühlen. Ich wollte sagen fühlen.
Dass Sie sich fühlen geht auch nicht. Dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben oder...
Ja?
Dass Sie diese Beschwerden empfinden.
Empfinden, okay.
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Manchmal zum Beispiel kommt das, wenn ich Fußball spiele.
Ja?
Manchmal kommt das, wenn ich arbeite. Manchmal kommt das auch, wenn ich Fernsehen gucke.
Fernsehen gucken, okay.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig beauftreten?
Ja, Kopfschmerzen.
Kopfschmerzen auch?
Und leiden Sie?
Allgemein habe ich auch Kopfschmerzen.
Okay.
Und Schwindel.
Schwindel auch, okay. Wichtig zu wissen.
Könnten Sie diese Kopfschmerzen genau beschreiben?
Wie soll ich Kopfschmerzen beschreiben? Kopfschmerzen halt.
Spüren Sie diese Kopfschmerzen im ganzen Kopf oder ein Teil des Kops?
Im ganzen Kopf würde ich sagen.
Im ganzen Kopf. Und sind Sie dauerhaft oder verschwinden Sie seitweise?
Oder wie lange dauert diese Attacke?
Unterschiedlich. Manchmal, wenn ich die Kopfschmerzen kriege, dann kann das manchmal bis zu zwei Stunden dauern.
Drei Stunden?
Manchmal auch länger.
Okay. Wie oft leiden Sie darunter? Zum Beispiel pro Monat?
Das habe ich auch seit ein paar Wochen. Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Das kommt und geht.
Manchmal habe ich nur ganz leichte Kopfschmerzen. Manchmal habe ich starke Kopfschmerzen.
Aber die treten halt auch. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich die Kopfschmerzen habe, wenn ich Fußball spiele oder wenn ich Treppen steige zum Beispiel.
Treppen steigen. Meinen Sie bei Belastung?
Ja, genau.
Okay, bei Belastung leiden Sie darunter. Und diese Schwindel, ich komme zu dieser Schwindel.
Wie können Sie das beschreiben? Wie auf dem Boot oder im Karussell?
Ach so, wenn ich jetzt den Schwindel beschreiben müsste, Sie müssen sagen, wenn Sie den Schwindel beschreiben müssten, wie fühlt es sich an?
Da dürfen Sie jetzt sagen, wie fühlt es sich an?
Wenn Sie den Schwindel beschreiben müssten, wie fühlt es sich an? So, als wären Sie auf einem Boot oder als wären Sie in einem Karussell?
Karussell, ja. Sie haben rechts. Okay.
Okay. Weiß ich nicht.
Okay. In den letzten ein paar Wochen. Wie oft leiden Sie darunter? Diese Schwindel?
In den letzten paar Wochen. Deswegen bin ich ja jetzt gekommen. Das hat zugenommen in letzter Zeit.
Also, dass ich nicht so gut einatmen kann, hat auch zugenommen in letzter Zeit. Deswegen bin ich ja da.
Meine Frau hat gesagt, da stimmt was nicht. Du musst jetzt mal zum Arzt gehen.
Ja, Sie haben die richtigste Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen, Herr Zimmer. Okay. Und die Häufigkeit oder, ja, die Urbefassung.
Und noch etwas? Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden? Neben diesen Beschwerden? Ich meine diese Kopfschmerzen und Schwindelattacken oder dieses komisches Brustgefühl?
Das ist so wie ein Druckwort. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, ich höre, ich merke mein Herz schlagen. Ja, das ist auch richtig.
Und ich höre auch das, als ob ich das hören würde, das Schlagen von meinem Herz.
Meinen Sie Ohrgeräusche oder nur während des Schlags?
Nein, das Herzschlag höre ich. Den Herzschlag, Entschuldigung, den Herzschlag höre ich.
Okay. Ist das auch attackenartig oder wie lange dauert dieser Herzschlag? Oder spüren Sie immer?
Nein, unterschiedlich. Nein, ich spüre das nicht immer. Manchmal. Okay. Das habe ich auch notiert, Herr Zimmer.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben, aber machen Sie sich keine Sorge. Wir werden die Ursache herausfinden und eine Lösung finden.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Stahlfluss, Nachschweiß oder Kaltenschweiß? Nein.
Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen? Sie haben ein Gefühl, Druckgefühl beschrieben.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie echte Brustschmerzen haben.
Ob es echte Schmerzen gibt, geht nicht. Ob es echte Brustschmerzen sind oder ob Sie echte Brustschmerzen haben.
Was meinen Sie denn mit echten Brustschmerzen? Ich lüge doch nicht. Natürlich habe ich keine Probleme.
Nein, natürlich. Sie haben recht. Aber ja, okay. Kein Problem.
Was meinen Sie denn damit mit echten Brustschmerzen?
Zum Beispiel Schmerzen. Das stört wirklich sehr. Nicht solche Beschwerden wie ein unbeschreibendes Gefühl. Aber echte, ich meine richtige Schmerzen.
Sie meinen, ob es Schmerzen sind oder eher ein Druckgefühl? Haben Sie es mal zu gucken? Alles klar.
Nur Druckgefühl haben Sie mir beschrieben. Das tut ja auch weh. Dieser Druckgefühl tut ja auch weh. Es ist ein Druckgefühl. Es ist kein richtiger Schmerz.
Okay. Richtig. Nur Druckgefühl. Okay. Und leiden Sie darunter nur bei Belastung. Im Ruhe haben Sie auch diese Beschwerden?
Das weiß man nicht. Das habe ich auch manchmal in Ruhe beim Fernsehen.
Okay. Auch in Ruhe. Okay. Ja, machen wir weiter. Ist Ihnen übel oder müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Kein Problem. Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Das klappt eigentlich auch immer ganz gut.
Immer ganz gut. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mit dem Appetit habe ich auch keine Probleme. Wissen Sie, das Problem ist nur ganz dieses drückende Gefühl in meiner Brust und diese Kopfschmerzen, die mittlerweile auftreten und immer länger andauern.
Und dieses Gefühl, na wie soll ich sagen, als würde ich ständig das Pochen von meinem Herz hören. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe Angst, dass ich sterben muss.
Okay. Waren Sie deswegen bei Matz? Oder ist das zum ersten Mal?
Ich bin zum ersten Mal hier.
Okay. Und gibt es etwas, das diese Beschwerde verstärkt oder lindert? Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Das lindert, kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen. Das geht von selbst wieder weg.
Selbst wieder weg?
Aber zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Fußball spiele, dann habe ich das. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel mich hinsetze und mich etwas aufruhe, so nach einer Stunde oder so, dann wird das weniger.
Weniger beim Hinsetzen oder in Ruhe? Weniger leiden Sie darunter?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, das wird dann langsam, aber langsam. Das dauert lange, aber es geht weg dann.
Langsam sind Sie weggegangen, aber selbst gegangen. Okay. Das habe ich mir notiert. Und Sie haben keine Ahnung mit Ihrem Gewicht.
Und schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme beim Schlaf, einzuschlafen oder Schwierigkeiten?
Wenn ich solche Beschwerden nicht habe, kann ich sehr gut einschlafen.
Okay. Haben Sie auch Konzentrationsstörungen heutzutage oder in letzter Zeit?
Nein.
Okay. Ja, Herr Max, Herr Zimmer, gibt es in Ihrer Vorgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Eigentlich nicht. Ich bin eigentlich gesund. Ich mache auch viel Sport eigentlich.
Ja.
Ich ernähre mich gesund. Ich lebe gesund. Ich mache viel Sport. Eigentlich nicht. Und deswegen beschäftigt mich das sehr. Warum habe ich das jetzt?
Ja, das ist natürlich, ich kann gut nachvollziehen.
Ja, nicht, dass ich ein Trio habe oder so, wissen Sie?
Wie gesagt, werden wir alle Möglichkeiten überprüfen. Machen Sie keine Sorge. Aber zuerst soll ich dieses Gespräch zum Ende führen.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nicht solich. Solich heißt, ich mache es im Radio. Nein, möchte ich das.
Okay. Möchte ich dieses Gespräch bis zum Ende führen?
Alles gut, zu Ende führen.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, ich...
Obwohl Sie sich gesucht haben.
Ja, vielleicht so mal. Wissen Sie, ich hatte immer wieder mal Stürze, so Fußballspielenverletzungen, solche Sachen.
Kleine Verletzungen?
Kleine, genau. Kleine Verletzungen beim Fußballspielen und so.
Okay. Und nehmen Sie...
Na ja, da ist auch schon mal mein Bein vielleicht gebrochen oder so. So was halt. Also wissen Sie, so beim Fußballspielen hat Verletzungen.
Ja. Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein, auch solche Ergänzungsstoffe?
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, meine Frau hat irgendwelche Vitamine gekauft, die nehme ich ein, aber ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen.
Okay, kein Problem. Sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt, Herr Zimmer?
Ja, ich habe eine Nickelallergie.
Nickelallergie? Wie äußert Sie sich?
Nickelallergie? Na ja, ich kann die Sachen nicht tragen, dann kriege ich Ausschlag auf der Haut.
Wenn Sie tragen, meine ich.
Ja.
Wenn Sie tragen, wie äußert Sie sich?
Hautausschlag.
Okay, Hautausschlag. Okay, das habe ich auch notiert. Und darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben, Herr Zimmer?
Nein, ich bin sportlich, ich rauche nicht und ich habe auch noch nie geraucht.
Ja, super. Ich gratuliere Ihnen. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so bei Feierlichkeiten, bei Gelegenheit.
Bei Feierlichkeiten? Vielleicht, was meinen Sie, mit Gelegenheit pro Woche oder pro Monat?
Ja, das sagt man so, bei Gelegenheit. Ja doch, bei Feierlichkeiten, so Geburtstagsfeiern zum Beispiel oder bei Feiern, Hochzeiten und so.
Sehr, sehr. Okay.
Sehr genau, selten.
Ich vermute, dass Sie keinen Kontakt mit Drogen haben.
Nein, richtig.
Richtig?
Gut zu hören. Und Sie treiben regelmäßig Sport, Sie achten viel auf gesunde Ernährung.
Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder zu Hause?
Eigentlich nicht.
Gut.
Na ja, ich meine, wer hat denn keinen Stress auf der Arbeit? Aber es ist jetzt nichts Außergewöhnliches.
Außergewöhnliches, okay. Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Und, ja, ich habe noch eine Frage zu Ihrer Familie. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Also meine Eltern leben beide noch.
Ja, gut.
Meine Eltern haben beide einen Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck, ja.
Und meine Mutter hat auch Stents.
Hat auch Stents. Meine Herzstents oder Gehirns?
Herzstents.
Herzstents, okay. Und ja, das habe ich noch notiert. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Schwester. Ist sie gesund oder hat sie irgendwelche gesundheitlichen Probleme?
Meine Schwester hat Bluthochdruck, ansonsten ist sie gesund.
Ansonsten gesund, ja. Okay. Ich würde gerne wissen, Herr Zimmer, ob Sie Kinder haben.
Nein.
Ich vermute, dass Sie verheiratet sind.
Ja, habe ich.
Sie haben so gesagt.
Okay. Keine Kinder. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Malermeister.
Malermeister. Okay. Ja. Okay, Herr Zimmer, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Ich habe nicht. Ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ja, ich habe so gesagt. Ich habe gesagt. Okay. Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig und ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihre Geduld.
Laut Ihrer Beschwerde habe ich einen Verdacht auf Herzklappenprobleme vielleicht.
Die Beschwerden, die Sie mir geschildert haben, passen dazu, aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung. Deswegen müssen wir weiter untersuchen und durchführen.
Was bedeutet das Herzklappenerkrankung? Was meinen Sie damit?
Ja, es kann sein. Wie gesagt, das ist nicht ein Verdacht. Ich habe einen Verdacht. Vielleicht haben Sie Probleme mit Ihren Herzklappen.
Und was heißt das? Ich habe Probleme damit. Was kann da passiert sein?
Ja, vielleicht. Es gibt, wie Sie wahrscheinlich wissen, es gibt Klappen in unserem Herz.
Und manchmal, obwohl wir unsere Gesundheit achten, leiden wir darunter, unter solchen Problemen.
Besonders bei Belastung können diese Klappen nicht gut funktionieren. Aber wie gesagt, das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt operiert werden?
Ja, es ist zu früh, solche Entscheidungen zu äußern. Aber jetzt werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen. Dann nehme ich Blut fürs Labor abnehmen.
Dann werde ich Blut fürs Labor abnehmen.
Und ich werde eine KG schreiben. Und ich werde auch einen Herzultraschall verlassen.
Und dann, sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, beschütze ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt. Dann komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Alles klar, vielen Dank. Sie waren sehr nett. Sie haben mir das sehr gut erklärt.
Okay. Danke.
Noch Fragen an unsere Patientin? Gibt es weitere Fragen?
Bitte?
Haben Sie in der Zeit Ihren Blutdruck gemessen?
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe eine Frage. Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass das Herzschlag regelmäßig schnell ist?
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen. Ich merke einfach nur, dass es sehr kräftig schlägt. Und ich höre das immer. Das ist so, als ob mein Herz aus meiner Brust rausgehen würde.
Okay. Okay, machen Sie weiter.
Hören Sie mit?
Bitte?
Ja, ich höre Sie.
Okay. Nehmen Sie bitte mit mit Kommentare ein.
Bitte was?
Nehmen Sie mit Medikamente ein.
Ich verstehe nicht, was ich einnehme. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig?
Medikamente?
Nein, nein. Er hat mich ja gefragt. Ich nehme keine Medikamente ein. Meine Frau hat mich...
Sind Ihnen heute Schwellung aufgefallen?
Bitte?
Ja, ich kann schreiben. Entschuldigung.
Ob mir eine Schwellung aufgefallen ist?
Ja, im Hals.
Im Hals? Nein, habe ich nicht. Falsch, nein. Nein.
Hier, was stimmt? Er war mir der Lippenmeer.
Eine Frage, ja. Bitte, Kollege.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Wie immer, ganz normal. Mein ein Kissen.
Ein Kissen, danke schön.
Sind Sie früher unmächtig?
Geworden?
Oder waren Sie schon mal bewusstlos? Nein, bewusstlos bin ich noch nie geworden.
Okay.
Nun möchte ich meinen Patienten vorstellen. Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, bitte.
Es geht um Herrn Max Zimmer. Er ist 48 Jahre alt, geboren am 1. April 1978.
Er ist 1,79 Meter groß und wiegt 81 Kilogramm.
Er kam heute zu uns wegen seit ein paar Wochen bestehender Schwindel, Kopfschmerzen und Druckgefühl im Brustkorb und auch Palpitationen.
Laut Aussage der Patientin sind diese Beschwerden...
Laut Aussage nicht der Patientin, dann wäre es auch...
...des Patientin, ja.
Laut Aussage des Patientin sind diese Beschwerden besonders bei Belastung plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Kopfschmerzen ungefähr zwei Stunden dauern und Schmerzen dauern.
Er spürt diese Schmerzen im ganzen Kopf.
Diese Schwindelattacke wurde vom Patienten als Schwankenschwindel...
Es ist keine Schwindelattacke.
Okay.
Tacke ist, wenn es ganz plötzlich kommt. So ist es ja nicht. Er hat Schwindel, wenn er diese Beschwerden hat.
Ja, begleiten.
Jetzt kann man einfach sagen, der Schwindel.
Wie bitte?
Einfach sagen, der Schwindel.
Der Schwindel, okay.
Ja, Vegetative anamnestisch ganz auffällig.
Außer diese... ja, ganz auffällig.
Aber die Beschwerden...
Auffällig oder unauffällig? Sie haben gesagt unauffällig.
Unauffällig, ja.
Die Beschwerden verschliessen sich bei Belastung oder Bewegung, während sie sich beim Hinsetzen bessern.
In Ruhe besser, nicht bei...
In Ruhe besser, ja, natürlich.
Ja, vor Erkrankung oder vor Operation anamnese oder auf die Medikamente anamnese sind unauffällig.
Er hat nie die Allergie...
Medikamente anamnese sind unauffällig, kann man nicht sagen.
Also, anamnese... das alles andere ist unauffällig und Medikamenten anamnese ist leer.
Also, er nimmt nichts ein, aber nicht unauffällig.
Aber es gibt nur Ergänzungstoffe nimmt der Patient, oder?
Ja, genau.
Deswegen habe ich es so gesagt.
Aber unauffällig sagt man nicht, weil Medikamenten einnehmen.
Medikamenten einnehmen entweder er nimmt Medikamente ein oder er nimmt keine Medikamente.
Kann man so sagen, zum Beispiel Medikamenten anamnese, kann man sagen?
Medikamenten anamnese kann man sagen.
Ok, ich sage so zum Beispiel Medikamente, Operationen oder vor Erkrankungen anamnese sind unauffällig.
Kann man so sagen?
Medikamenten anamnese unauffällig habe ich noch nie gehört, würde ich nicht sagen.
Kann man sagen, das sagt der Prüfer nichts, das ist nicht schlimm.
Aber vor Operationen und das war, ist alles sehr gut, ist unauffällig.
Medikamente nimmt der Patient nicht ein, bis auf Nahrungsergänzung.
Ja, würde ich so sagen. Aber das ist meine persönliche.
Medikamenten anamnese ist leer, sagen wir eigentlich.
Leer heißt, da ist nichts.
Aber Medikamenten anamnese ist unauffällig, ist immer unaufällig.
Es gibt immer einiges, das geht nicht.
Ja, sie haben nichts.
Der Patient hat keine Allergie, die sich durch Exanthem äußert.
Bei den Noxen anamnese berichtete er über den gelegentlichen Alkoholkonsum.
Nikotin und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Er trägt regelmäßig Sport, kein Stress entweder zu Hause oder bei der Arbeit.
Die Familie anamnese ergab arterielle Hypertonie beim Vater und auch arterielle Hypertonie bei der Mutter.
Ja, Vater, Mutter und Schwester haben arterielle Hypertonie.
Sozial anamnestisch ist er verheiratet, kein Kind, er ist Malermeister.
Nach den anamnestischen Angaben habe ich auf eine arterielle Hypertonie bei diesem Patienten verdacht.
Die Patienten haben mir während des Gesprächs geschildert, wie Herzpalpitationen oder Schwindel oder auch Kopfschmerzen.
Bei Belastungen verschlimmende Beschwerden passen dazu.
Zu Herzklappenfehlern meinen Sie?
Für die Patientin war das anders, aber jetzt habe ich ein bisschen anders denken.
Was haben Sie gedacht nochmal?
Arterielle Hypertonie denke ich.
Wegen der Familienbelastung habe ich meinen Verdacht verändert.
Die wichtigste Punkt ist natürlich die familiäre Belastung.
Bei den Eltern und Schwester haben sie arterielle Hypertonie.
Das ist für mich sehr entscheidend.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Was nehmen Sie denn ab?
Blut.
Was ist denn wichtig?
Am Labor würde ich Blutbildentzündungsparameter, Leber- und Nierenwerte und BNP kontrollieren lassen.
Und auch Urinstatus sind wichtig.
Was hat der Tatsache für einen Hauptbeschwerden?
Hauptbeschwerden sind nicht gut beschrieben.
Kopfschmerzen und Schwindel.
Nein.
Und auch Palpitation.
Druck auf der Brust?
Ja, Druck auf der Brust und auch auf der Kopfschmerzen.
Was müssen Sie im Labor noch machen?
Herzmuskelenzymen kontrollieren lassen.
Neben BNP.
Herzmuskelenzymen.
Was machen Sie da? Welche Werte machen Sie da?
Meinen Sie als Herzmarker CKMB und Troponin.
Sehr gut. Und BNP.
Und BNP.
Sie sind ja jetzt im Krankenhaus. Sie gehen ja immer vom Krankenhaus aus.
Im Krankenhaus machen die immer NT pro BNP.
In der Praxis machen die BNP. Im Krankenhaus machen die NT pro BNP. NT pro BNP ist ja auch empfindlicher, sensibler.
Was machen Sie noch? Ein Wert noch.
Was machen Sie noch?
Und Urin.
Elektrolyten natürlich.
Leberwerte, Elektrolyte, Blutbild, Gerinnung. Alles richtig.
Herzinzyme haben Sie gesagt. Herzinzyme müssen Sie ganz am Anfang sagen.
Das ist natürlich der Reihenfolge.
Weil ich in Komp habe.
Was noch? Der Prüfer liegt aber darauf Wert.
Er will wissen, ob Sie gut nachdenken können.
Abarbeiten die Diagnosen.
Ich denke, der Patient könnte haben.
Also mache ich auf jeden Fall die Herzenzyme.
CK, CKMB, Troponin.
Ich mache NT pro BNP. Herzinzyme, Blablabla.
Und was noch? Ein Wert fehlt mir noch.
Ein Wert haben Sie nicht gesagt.
Ich sage das bei allen meinen Vorträgen immer.
Lipid Profil.
Meinen Sie?
Nein.
Im Labor.
Ich sage das bei allen meinen Vorträgen.
Ich kann nicht Sie hören.
Wenn der Patient Brustschmerzen angebt.
Dann muss man immer noch an eine Sache mitgehen.
Meinen Sie Dedimera?
Richtig, genau.
Und andere Gärungsparameter ist auch wichtig.
Warum möchte ich die Dedimera bei dem Patienten haben?
Damit können wir eine wahrscheinlich Pulmonare-Amboli ausschließen.
Genau. Und warum?
Ich kann ja nicht einfach bei jedem 48-jährigen Patienten.
Das ist ein junger Patient. Sportlich, fit.
Ich kann doch nicht bei jedem Patienten einfach Dedimera machen.
Warum möchte ich bei diesem Patienten die Dedimera haben?
Weil dieser Druckbefehl...
Genau, er hat gesagt, er kann dann nicht gut einatmen.
Deswegen ist das völlig korrekt bei diesem Patienten zu machen.
TSH, Freitag, T4 würde ich kontrollieren lassen im Labor.
Warum?
Weil eine...
Natürlich, obwohl der Patient eine entscheidende familiäre Belastung hat.
Soll ich auch die sekundäre Ursache recherchieren.
Deswegen...
Nicht nur, warum auch?
Was spricht dafür?
Warum muss man...
Das hat Palpitationen.
Genau, Palpitationen.
Und Schwindel hat.
Schwindel hat Schwindel.
Wegen der Palpitation muss man die Schilddrüse abklären.
Das macht man bei jedem Patienten.
Ja, okay, super.
Aber auf jeden Fall kontrolliere ich auch Rübenstatus.
Weil, ob möglich, vielleicht...
Aber ganz zum Schluss sagen.
Nicht erst Urinstatus, dann Herzinzyme bitte.
Sondern erst Herzinzyme, die wichtigsten Sachen, Dedimeren.
Und dann Rübenstatus.
Darauf achten die Prüfer.
Ich weiß, dass Sie das wissen.
Aber das wissen die Prüfer nicht.
Die Prüfer wählen nur durch das Hören, wie sie denken.
Haben Sie verstanden?
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Dedimere habe ich gesagt.
Herzinzyme haben Sie gesagt.
Die wichtigsten Sachen haben wir jetzt genannt.
BNP haben Sie gesagt.
Das haben Sie selber schon gesagt.
Das war super.
Was machen Sie als nächstes?
Blut haben wir jetzt abgenommen.
EKG haben Sie schon geschrieben, hoffe ich.
Das machen Sie als allererstes mit dem Blut abnehmen.
Machen Sie auch EKG gleich mit.
Meinen Sie Reihenfolge?
Reihenfolge ist auch wichtig.
Sie nehmen das Blut ab und schreiben sofort ein EKG.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Und dann?
Dann können Sie eine Herzultraschall veranlassen.
Vielleicht mit einem kardiologischen Konsil.
Aber davor haben Sie noch etwas ganz Einfaches gemacht.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung messe ich alle vitalen Parameter.
Ein schließlich Bluthochdruck.
Deswegen wollte ich das nicht nennen.
Ja, doch, das muss man sagen.
Ich dachte, dass die vitalen Parameter ein Teil des Körperes sind.
Ich habe das gehört.
Vital Parameter reicht aus.
Das ist richtig bei diesem Patienten.
Dieser Patient hat nämlich immer Werte um die 180, 200 systolisch.
Der hat das schon so lange, dass er sich daran gewöhnt hat.
Und dass er mittlerweile aber Kopfschmerzen schon hat.
Dadurch hat sich das bemerkbar gemacht.
Das ist ganz viel.
Ich bin jetzt auch in der Praxis im Krankenhaus im Notfall.
Wenn ich mit dem Notarztwagen unterwegs bin,
im Notfall sehe ich akute hypertensive Krisen.
Die treten ganz plötzlich auf Schmerzen.
Starke Brustschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen.
In der Praxis sehe ich Patienten, die immer wieder mal so wie Druckgefühl,
Palpitationen, ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen nicht so ganz richtig beschreiben können,
weil sie so viel Blutdruck haben.
Dann machen wir Langzeitblutdruck und dann haben die eine hypertensive Blutdruckwerte.
Erstdiagnose ist oft.
Aber ist richtig.
Aber mit den Herzklappenfehlern, das war nicht richtig.
Herzklappenfehler war nicht richtig.
Sie haben nichts.
Weil bei Herzklappenfehlern dürfen Sie so nicht sofort als Hauptdiagnose sagen.
Das dürfen Sie nur sagen, dass Sie vermuten, dass das ein Herzklappenfehler ist.
Nur bei welchen Patienten müssen Sie sagen, das könnte ein Herzklappenfehler sein?
Die selben Symptome, Druckgefühl, Schwindel.
Welche Klappenerkrankung macht das?
Bei Belastung, besonders bei Sportverhalten.
Welche?
Die Hautklappensternose.
Richtig. Aber wie muss das Alter sein?
Wie alt muss der Patient dann sein?
Ein bisschen älter sein.
Immer.
Ich habe extra.
Ich hätte ja auch eigentlich gemein sein können.
Wenn ich gemein gewesen wäre, dann hätte ich gesagt, der Patient ist 70.
Dann hätten Sie noch mehr Probleme gehabt.
Dann hätten Sie sagen können, ja, eine Hautklappensternose kann es sein.
Aber ich habe extra gesagt, junger Patient.
Und immer die Prinzipialdiagnosen sagen.
Nicht, ich vermute, dass es eine Herzklappenerkrankung ist.
Sondern das Problem könnte ein kardiales Problem sein.
Herzproblem.
Erstmal generell. Es könnte sich hierbei um ein Herzproblem handeln.
Zum Beispiel könnte es sein, dass der Patient, er hat zwar keine hohen Risikofaktoren.
Aber die Mutter hat ja eine Herzenfarkt. Die Mutter hat Stents.
Deswegen hätten Sie sagen müssen bei der Differenzialdiagnose, es kann ja sein, dass der Patient eine coronare Herzerkrankung hat.
Und ich muss aber trotzdem auf eine Lungenembolie ausgrenzen.
Obwohl ich nicht denke, dass es könnte sein.
Aber weniger wahrscheinlich. Die wahrscheinlichste Diagnose müssen Sie so ausgehen.
Mutter hat Herzinfarkt. Er hat Drogschmerzen.
Passt aber nicht die Kopfschmerzen.
Also können Sie sagen, da alle auch arterielle Hypertonie haben, könnte es auch ein Blutdruckproblem sein.
Weiß ich nicht. Das sind alles Differenzialdiagnosen.
Das werden wir bei der Untersuchung rausbekommen.
Und wenn dabei nichts rauskommt, wenn das Herz gesund ist und er hat immer noch den Schwindel, dann müssen Sie natürlich auch neurologisch erklären.
Hier, vor allem CT-Karotid-Doppler.
CT-Karotid-Doppler.
CT oder zuerst Karotid-Doppler?
Nein, erst CT. Karotid-Doppler kommt ganz zum Schluss.
Das machen wir in der Klinik gar nicht. Das ist zu auswendig.
Das dauert zu lange.
Weil in der Klinik, was könnte dann an dem Karotid-Doppler sein?
Wann macht man denn einen Karotid-Doppler? Wenn man einen Schwindel hat, macht man das nicht.
Wann macht man den Karotid-Doppler?
Das ist jetzt für alle und das müssen sich jetzt alle, alle merken.
Man macht nicht bei Schwindel Karotid-Doppler.
Wann macht man und muss man einen Karotid-Doppler machen?
Immer Schlaganfall.
Warum? Weil Karotid-Doppler bedeutet nur, da ist Kalk an den Karotiden oder an den Hirnversorgenden Gefäßen und das könnte sich abgelöst haben.
Das macht Schlaganfall. Aber kein Schwindel.
Ja, bei Schwindel oder irgendwie neurologischen Symptomen großzügig CT vom Kopf machen.
Kranklos macht man das nur.
Weil das ist keine Notfallindikation Karotid-Doppler.
Verstehen Sie, was ich meine? Notfallindikation zu gucken, hat der Schwindel, hat er eine Basilaristrombose, hat er irgendwas.
Erstmal CT. Dann sind Sie völlig richtig raus.
Also ich könnte sagen, wenn ich das Kardiale abgeklärt habe, wenn er das nicht hat, ich vermute, er hat einen Blutdruck oder so, wenn er das alles nicht hat, dann ist das ein Schwindel.
Dann mache ich noch ein CT vom Kopf.
Oder Sie machen es gleichzeitig. Aber Sie haben das gut gemacht. Das war schon gut.
Also es war ein Status vor der Herd-Synzome. Das geht gar nicht.
Erst Herd-Synzome-Diätimere, ganz zum Schluss Urinstatus.
Es sei denn, der Patient beschreibt ganz andere Symptome und sagt nicht, er hat Herzschmerzen, sondern er hat Blasenschmerzen oder er hat Blut im Urin.
Dann müssen Sie natürlich Urinstatus zuerst sagen.
Okay, also Symptom-orientiertes Labor.
Und das andere, was mir nicht so gut gefallen hat, ist in der Noxenanamnese.
Das hört sich so streng an. Noxenanamnese.
Sagt man das so? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe noch nie gehört, dass Sie gesagt haben Noxenanamnese.
Alkohol wird nicht als Nox angesehen. Verstehen Sie, was ich meine?
Das ist ja so, viele trinken Alkohol. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe noch nie gehört, dass Sie gesagt haben Noxenanamnese. Gucken Sie mal, ob man das so sagen kann.
Ich habe das so nie gehört in der Noxenanamnese.
Wir haben in Kursen immer so, aber ich bin mir nicht so...
Ach so, Sie sagen das so. Bei Ihnen sagt man das so.
Ich sage ja, ich habe das nicht gehört, aber sonst war alles nicht wahr.
Ich sage das sehr gut, es hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Ihr Zsersen ist keine Sorge.
Danke für alle Bewerbungen.